it's beyond what the thurible stock
exchange in Riyadh could have ever
imagined the world's largest
oil-producing firm is being listed here
and shares are expected to be priced in
December it's happening after years of
hype and several delays Aramco is no
ordinary company it's the engine driving
Saudi Arabia's economy which relies on
oil revenues the centerpiece of Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman is vision
2030 Saudi Aramco is supposed to bring
in enough revenue to diversify the
economy but it's never listed in any of
the world's leading exchanges because of
transparency fears the first idea was
either to listed either in New York
London or in Hong Kong Kong but there
have been some issues especially
regarding the New York Stock Exchange
listing and which was the possible
litigation or no Peck law that could
have been adopted by the US Congress
therefore there were some concerns by
Saudis and this was expecting that
Saudis would go for the domestic market
listing the ambitious Crown Prince set
out a two trillion dollar price tag to
put that into context the world's most
valuable companies such as Microsoft and
Apple stand at half of what the Prince
wanted these firms have a market
capitalization of around a trillion
dollars if Aramco failed to reach the
coveted two trillion target the
conference would either have to swallow
the lower valuation or postpone the IPO
once again that two trillion number
actually came from nowhere there was no
justification or nothing that
substantiate that number and that number
was started floating around in 2016 when
the the first idea of IPO came to the
public from the Mohammed bin Salman and
a lot of things happened actually
throughout this period for a listing
outside of the kingdom Aramco would have
had to prove its reserves are what it
says they are analysts believe the
difference between probable and proven
oil reserves can vary for foreign
investors the biggest concern is about
the safety of their investment in
September an attack by Houthi rebels in
Yemen reduced by half the companies or
production investors a cautious of Saudi
Arabia's neighborhood with an ISIL
infested Iraqi desert in the West and
Iran allied Houthi rebels in the South a
self-inflicted crisis with Qatar in the
east and brewing tension in the Strait
of Hormuz no one expected that Houthis
or any other non-state actors could be
so successful in in disrupting the oil
production that also had its impact on
on the lower evaluation investors also
have to consider the opaque
anti-corruption Drive which was seen as
a shakedown of wealthy Saudis and the
public relations disaster of journalists
jamala shock jeez gruesome killing which
was linked directly to the crown prince
this talk of an international offering
after the initial listing in Saudi
Arabia the Saudi Crown Prince wants to
press ahead with privatizing five
percent of the kingdom's most valuable
company Saudi Arabia has tried to lure
investors from Asia to Europe and from
Russia to the United States there are
reports that Saudi Arabia is still
holding government-to-government
meetings to attract investment from
sovereign wealth funds industry experts
believe much of the investment from the
riyadh listing will come from wealthy
Saudi families not foreign investors
it's curious timing for the IPO with a
weak outlook for oil prices a bearish
global economy and increase
environmental awareness against the use
of fossil fuels Osama bin Javed Al
Jazeera let's bring you in Ibrahim Frei
hotties an associate professor at the
Doha Institute for Graduate Studies
thanks for speaking to us on al Jazeera
so it's been an IPO that's been on again
off again now it seems to be on and
report it seems to suggest that the
crown prince is now willing to accept
less than that to truly in dollar
valuation that he had once hoped for how
significant is this IPO for the kingdom
well it's very significant actually and
for many reasons when Aramco represents
the backbone of the Saudi economy and to
have this giant company on sale for
privatisation in this sense an important
message about the control of the economy
and the sovereignty of the state because
this is Aramco is about sovereignty for
Saudi Arabia and here is that the
kingdom is putting this important part
of its economy for privatization so this
is one and two there is the important
factor of trust how much the investors
are going to trust in this investing in
in a company that has been attacked
lately by the Houthis and the political
stability of the region yeah because
this is the most probably the most
critical time in terms of security for
Saudi Arabia and for unarmed Gulf
alright so what we saw from that attack
the seven weeks ago at the Aramco oil
fields is that these oil fields have
been vulnerable so has that
vulnerability gone away or to what
extent do you think political risk still
exists now this is going to represent a
very serious challenge the political
stability of the region because it's I
mean for investors the very major
requirement they need for their money
and for their investment is first of all
is stability and security which is not
the case this has not been the case in
Saudi Arabia since probably two or three
decades that we're getting this level of
instability and you know the Saudi
system is unable to protect to protect
its oil companies with all the arms
purchases that it got from the United
States in order you know to do this so
stability is a major factor and there is
also the trust issue which is that the
Saudi Kingdom needs the support of the
south and the wealthy Saudis in order to
back this step and to be able to invest
in this and here we should mention that
you know the ritz-carlton corruption
investigation where large number of
South the
unis were arrested under allegations of
of corruption and surrendered large
parts of their wealth and the estimate
of of the width that Mohammed bin Salman
gather from them of about 100 billion
dollars so those will be Saudis were
expected to be the major supporters of
such a step
now if they don't have the money and be
to what extent they or others really
trust this kind of synth or zation
decisions coming from the crown prince
directly and they're willing to invest
in this level so this is definitely
another serious challenge that we're
going to see in this IPO and one last
question to you because we understand or
report suggests that this IPO is
starting as a domestic IPO and then it
will see through an international sale
at a later date so to what extent is the
crown prince in Saudi Arabia keen to
attract foreign investment will they see
that foreign investment through and how
does this all fit into his economic
reform agenda yeah well this again the
very first step is going to be with
local investors and how much they're
going to you know to invest in this
which is again in terms of the stability
and the trust in the leadership it's not
major it's not there so and this will
you know to what extent this will be
successful in terms of on the domestic
ma and the domestic market this is going
also to send a message you know to the
international market and how much
international visitors are going to send
this so the timing is definitely the
worst in my view this could have been
done at least before we saw the Houthis
attacking Saudi Arabia the Saudi
Arabia's oil company Aramco which could
have been a much better situation and in
my view it would have been much smarter
for the conference is to try to get some
political instability before they engage
into this kind of major step that's
going to put you know the Saudi economy
on the line for this okay but I
thank you for giving us your analysis
thank you